ces messieurs bonsoir bienvenue dans la
quinzième émissions des warner je
continuais à découvrir des talents
s'amuser tout en chantant pendant le
confinement la voie en scène créé un
talk un live de près de deux heures il y
a donc si six candidats sélectionnés par
le public
donc le public vote les candidats en
fait envoient leurs leurs vidéos par un
par internet par par les réseaux sociaux
donc instagram donc le public vote
et puis ceux qui sont sélectionnés passe
sur le live du mercredi et puis on a un
ou deux invités le soir et deux
professionnels invités avec moi ça fait
3 animé pendant deux jours pendant le
confinement l'émission a gardé un numéro
hebdomadaire depuis le 11 mai l'occasion
aussi pour les organisateurs de lancer
le prochain tremplin des voix le sixième
trois auditions
deux auditions donc une audition à magny
les hameaux le 14 novembre
une audition à paris aux alentours du 21
au 28 novembre
ça reste à définir et une audition à la
réunion à l'île de la réunion le 12
décembre normalement si tout va bien
les inscriptions pour le tremplin seront
ouvertes le 15 juillet prochain les voix
aux nerfs continue
prochain rendez vous ce mercredi 8
juillet